woke Insanity coming for Biden's border
crisis a new democrat-backed Bill wants
to make it harder to detain certain
groups of migrants deemed vulnerable
persons it would quote create a
presumption of release and impose a
higher burden of proof to detain primary
caregivers and vulnerable populations
including Asylum Seekers pregnant women
lgbtq individuals survivors of torture
or gender-based violence and people
under the age of 21 and if you didn't
make that list why it you trying hard
but Democrats on the front lines of the
migrant crisis have a much different
perspective like New York city mayor
Eric Adams
this is
to fight for the resources that's
going to undermine every agency in our
city
whoa that was quite the admission from a
mayor who's actually in power now judge
they want to radically change credible
fear in this country and what it takes
to get an early release but that
admission is pretty Stark well there's a
couple of things first of all let's
figure out another way to distract the
overburdened disheartened demoralized
border patrol so that they don't watch
for the cartels all right let me count
the ways already they're babysitters
they're busing people they're feeding
people they're changing diapers and now
they have to figure out who might be
lesbian gay bisexual transgender queer
intersexual limited English language
proficiency isn't that
isn't this Administration saying we want
everybody to come in and if you say that
you are a victim of anything they're
going to let you in and the amazing part
is title 42 is going to be lifted
mayorkas has yet to unveil a plan for
title 42. and as it relates to Mayor
Adams mayor Adams has said 56 000
immigrants have destroyed New York City
at a cost of 4.3 billion now the way I
figure it and I'm not good with math if
we've got 4 million illegals here and of
course 4.3 billion for 56 000 we have to
maximize that maximize that by 115 to
how do the American people pay for this
right how can we afford this burden does
anybody care
Harold you and I we both served in
Congress Democrats had the House and
Senate and the presidency I didn't see
them introducing this when they had all
the levers of control you guys have had
it for a while too and didn't do it this
is a bipartisan but I wouldn't do this
bill regardless
I don't disagree but I'm just saying
that this is bipartisan the mess now is
on the on the Democrats have the
majority and I would agree with you and
Republicans are in the house I think
they should I'd be producing I was just
I admired Jim Jordan for going down to
the border to hold a hearing to talk
about these things but I'm glad we're in
the business of accepting Eric Adams as
a convert because he was not totally
many of us around his table immigration
now he's coming around now what
democrats should do the bill there are a
bunch of bills as you and I know they're
introducing Congress most of them
um are not worth the paper they're
written on
democrats should be focused on what Eric
Adams and those Mayors talked about in
D.C a few days ago where they not only
were urging that the federal government
spend more money to help but I think
whenever you encourage Congress to spend
you force them to think and I think we
as a nation need to understand that set
of uh of rule or things that you talked
about the qualification you said it best
who wouldn't qualify or who can't
qualify under one of those things you
just increase until your point judge you
do distract them from the jobs they're
doing we need more ice workers we need
more uh people at the border more law
enforcement we need a wall those are the
things we should be talking about as
well as an asylum process that's sorted
out and an ability to to integrate those
who've been here 15 20 years who pay
taxes into our society this here
distracts from that it's not serious
it's dumb and frankly it's dangerous
yeah I I think what's interesting here
is Democrats had the opportunity to
participate in a hearing on the border
and they they abandoned that opportunity
they blew it off so I know that the
White House might say this legislation
the suggestion on the lgbtq is not our
legislation that's just some Democrats
in Congress oh no if the White House is
going to say that every Republican will
be tarred and feathered with one
senator's suggestion for figuring out a
way to deal with Social Security and
Medicare in the future and you will own
this and everybody shall know that the
White House is actually for this that's
what we're going to say so the other
thing is the Biden Administration for
having blown this off so long is that
they've made it so much harder to get
legislation passed yeah okay because
until you deal with the security issue
nobody wants to talk about anything else
in the meantime you have Farmers you
can't get their crops picked with legal
temporary Visa migrant labor and so
what's going to happen that fruit will
rot on the vine or what makes it to the
store will be so much more expensive and
everybody will pay for it and again just
keep adding up how much you are paying
how much more you're paying in the last
two years than you did before that now
the last thing I will say is isn't it
shocking that the New York Times can
write a huge investigative piece about
migrant children
having to work under terrible conditions
and the rest of the media is like Sandra
Bullock in that movie Bird Box like is
it bird box or yeah but she can't see
anything I think the media is like oh I
never saw that New York Times report
even though they live and die by the New
York Times it's really shameful that
they turn everybody's ignoring it
pretending like if they could just get
Biden across the Finish Line then
everything's going to be solved
nothing's going to be solved if you
don't actually deal with the issues at
hand Craig can you solve this for us I'm
troubled by the Sandra Bullock reference
I don't know that movie
has the blindfold on all the time oh
that's a different movie all right why
did Adams come around because policy met
consequences right everybody thought
that was a stunt but we've been
Sanctuary cities feel the but they feel
the cost of their own virtue signaling
you actually get a convert but I think
that the thing that bugs us most in this
kind of story or it bugs me maybe is the
protected class idea is now absurd once
you can identify defy as it it's not
like you can look at somebody and go
you're a protected class I can tell
you're like you might be you might be an
injured War veteran you might you it's
obvious but when you could say I am this
you create an incentive for deception
you get benefits from your identity and
we know this and so how will you detect
the truth when somebody a legal alien
says hey I I you know this is who I am
you have to ask him who he has sex with
uh and if you're straight are you
detained because that's a hell of an
incentive for lying and it also happens
to be discrimination to make that to to
say okay you guys get get in you people
don't but we're already kind of at the
mercy of this bizarre logic of the
protected class the country's imploded
under this tiny fraction of people
commanding more than just respect and
basic rights they are demanding Superior
rights and benefits that you have to pay
for even if they're in jail and that's
different that's not equality that's
inequality that's uh that's a punitive
punishment against basically every
American who has to pay for it Dana's
right that movie is called Bird Box
oh you would think of that other
you know that one
Fox News YouTube page this is the only
way that I know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on Fox you can get it
all here on YouTube so subscribe right
now